les ont occupés aujourd'hui sont fermés
est-ce que désormais il ya un risque de
voir s'installer un conflit militaire
sur la durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi qu'on a guère a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum interne à
sion vous laissez les sahraouis le choix
de choisir le futur de choisir entre
l'indépendance et l'intégration maroc à
savoir que ce n'est pas une partie du
territoire marocain
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 30 juin plus
de trois heures et demie de
questions-réponses vladimir poutine a
répondu aux interrogations des
téléspectateurs russes lors d'un rendez
vous incontournable et annuel line
direct un grand oral marqué cette année
par des questions liées à la crise
sanitaire et à la vaccination
le pays enregistre un nouveau triste
record 669 personnes décédées du que
vides lors des dernières 24 heures en
bus les jardins d évacuer cette nuit par
l'amérique paris ce parc du nord-est de
la capitale souhaitée depuis plusieurs
semaines par des toxicomanes est depuis
sous la surveillance de crs sauf que les
consommateurs eux arpente désormais les
rues du quartier les riverains sont
rassemblés ce soir
l'insomnie de lusine lubrizol la cour
d'appel de paris confirme la mise en
examen de la société rejetant ainsi le
recours de l'entreprise américaine qui
dénonçait des irrégularités dans l'
enquête après l'incendié en septembre
la décision a été immédiatement salué
par les parties civiles
[Musique]
plus de trois heures et demie de
questions-réponses donc à la mi journée
entre vladimir poutine et ses
concitoyens le nom de ce traditionnel
rendez vous annuel ligne directe a pour
but de permettre aux citoyens russes
d'interroger le chef du kremlin
au menu de nombreux sujets
internationaux le point tout de suite
avec la correspondance et moscou de
veyra goffman bonsoir verra une grande
partie de ce rendez vous était consacrée
évidemment à la pandémie
bonsoir stéphanie oui effectivement la
pandémie de coronavirus mais aussi
l'économie les dossiers internationaux
plus de deux millions de questions
étaient envoyés pour cette ligne directe
avec la dîme routine cette année
l'exercice a duré seulement 3 heures 42
minutes
le chef d'état russe a répondu à 169
question la plupart des roquettes porté
sur la gestion justement de la crise
sanitaire en russie la hausse des
contaminations colis de 19 étant
préoccupante
le président russe a encouragé les
russes à se faire vacciner mais s'est
opposé à toute obligation à l'échelle
nationale écoutez les décisions des
administrations des dix régions
justement cette fonction d'éviter le
confinement plus que le confinement
c'est ce sont les gens qui restent sans
salaire ce sont les banqueroutes des pme
et la baisse des revenus des gens alors
pour l'éviter dans certaines régions on
prévoit la vaccination obligatoire pour
éviter la diffusion de l'épisode et les
peaux l'épidémie il n'y a qu'une seule
voie
la vaccination nous avons cette
possibilité parce que nous avons quatre
vaccins et qui sont hautement
technologiques très sécurisée et
efficace et j'espère que certaines
certaine retenue de nos gens vont
disparaître
la dmr poutine a finalement avoué
qu'elle vaccin avait été choisi pour se
faire vacciner le président russe a opté
pour spoutnik ville justifié son choix
par le fait qu'ils t'en chiffres des
armes il devait recevoir la même église
élections que ces soldats et verra le
sujet de l'ukraine a également été
évoqué lors de ce grand oral
même si les spectateurs s'intéressait
plus à la politique intérieure
cette année la politique extérieure
était également évoqué les spectateurs à
l'antenne de roger vladimir poutine
concernant les relations russo
ukrainiennes et une possible rencontre
avec le président ukrainien wladimir
zielinski le chef d'état russe s'est dit
à être fermé à la rencontre avec son
homologue ukrainien mais mais assez
réticent quant à son utilité
parce que selon vladimir poutine look et
j'ai géré de l'extérieur écouter les
gens sont confinés dans leur propre
mandat mais je ne crois pas que le
peuple ukrainien c'est un peuple aussi
la russie non pas du tout nous faisons
un ensemble tandis que les autorités
ukrainiennes actuelle ce occupe une
position hostile envers la russie ça
c'est évident à quoi bon nous rencontrer
avec monsieur zelensky 6 et l'ukraine
sous l'autorité de céline ce qu'ils sont
contrôlés de l'extérieur est les aspects
clés de la vie en ukraine sont décidées
à washington à berlin à paris mais bien
sûr je ne renonce pas à ces rencontres
là mais je veux comprendre a de quoi on
va parler il a également déclaré qu'il
allait bientôt écrire un article sur les
relations troubles la russie et son
voisin ukrainien
elle verra le président russe qui a
également évoqué à les relations
diplomatiques avec les états unis
bien sûr impossible d'imaginer une ligne
directe sont les questions sur les
relations russo américaines après le
sommet byden poutine à genève les
spectateurs russes
demandez à quoi ça servait de rencontrer
le président américain
nos partenaires à berthe écarts
comprennent d'un côté et cette évolution
c'est pourquoi il ya la rencontre à
genève mais de l'autre côté
coûte que coûte il persiste à dominer
toujours le monde et il ya de ce fait
toutes sortes de menaces cette prise de
conscience du monde qui évolué dans ce
monde qui évolue il y aura la nouvelle
prise conscience de ses propres
priorités de ses propres intérêts et
cela va amener vers la situation où là
le monde soit plus raisonnable plus
équilibrée et nos échanges avec les
états unis seront normalisées après
avoir remercié les téléspectateurs et
les différents intervenants le dit ma
routine a conclu cette ligne directe par
une promesse de faire tout son possible
pour que chaque demande chaque roquette
chaque appel soit l'objet de son
attention
merci verhaeghe hoffman pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de moscou
et pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
soir claude blanchemaison merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
tout d'abord quelle impression globale
se dégage de ce grand oral cette année
le projet de l'abbaye routine
manifestement très à l'aise pendant plus
de 3 heures 40 durant lesquelles il a
répondu à une centaine de questions de
russes c'est le dix huitième exercice
annuel de ce genre et il est
particulièrement à l'aise avec ces
questions dont la plupart portent sur la
politique intérieure ce qui préoccupe
véritablement le citoyen russe c'est ce
qui le préoccupe c'est d'abord le coût
de la vie et à cela la drire poutine
répond mais la banque centrale vient de
hausser ses taux directeurs de façon à
réduire les le niveau de l'inflation qui
doit passer dans les prochains mois qui
doit être réduite 2% de deux points dans
les prochains mois pour la hausse des
prix alimentaires le gouvernement a pris
et va prendre des mesures pour limiter
cette hausse
même chose pour la hausse des produits
de la construction
et puis pour le reste et bien
généralement et cette année encore les
intervenants qui pose des questions
pointe du doigt un manquement des
autorités locales
par exemple une une personne dit mais
pourquoi est ce que la location que je
tousse y toucher pour élever mon enfant
qui est dans un âge entre entre 4 et 7
ans eh bien je ne la touche plus on me
dit localement que c'est parce que je ne
peux pas démontré que j'ai eu 12 mois de
salaire l'année précédente et bien
entendu à cause du coville à cause du
chômage
il est évident que je ne peux pas des me
fait ces démonstrations et le président
poutine répond mais c'est illégal et à
ce moment là les oreilles du gouverneur
local doivent siffler et c'est comme ça
à chaque année puisque effectivement les
questions posent des les pose le doigt
sur des manquements des autorités
locales qui sont mal interprétés
la loi fédérale soit non pas appliquer
des directives gouvernementales
donc c'est utile c'est utile pour les
citoyens est aussi utile pour le
président parce que ça lui permet de
voir quelles sont les préoccupations de
la population et aussi de voir dans
quelle mesure les directives globales
sont appliquées dans les différentes
régions donc c'est sans doute une
épreuve un petit peu difficile pendant
quatre heures pour les gouverneurs des
différentes régions en tout cas vladimir
poutine a été très clair sur sa volonté
de vacciner le plus possible la
population
il faut vacciner et là dessus la lumière
poutine a tenu le même langage que
beaucoup d'autres chefs d'état et de
gouvernement il faut vacciner bien
entendu massivement lui-même a dit qu'il
avait été vaccinée dès le mois de
février avec le vaccin spoutnik que vais
bien entendu et que comme les forces
armées comme beaucoup de monde en russie
simplement il ya une certaine réticence
d'une partie de la population russe et
peut-être d'ailleurs une partie de cette
réticence est dû au fait que à l'époque
soviétique
les vaccinations était obligatoire
vladimir poutine a souligné le fait
qu'elles ne sont plus obligatoires et
que dans la loi votée en 1804 mineurs en
1998 par la douma
eh bien il ya des vaccinations
obligatoires mais d'autres qui ne le
sont pas ça c'est pour la glff fédéral
il a vivement encouragé les autorités
locales c'est-à-dire les gouverneurs les
maires des grandes villes à rendre
obligatoire cette vaccination pour
certaines professions naturellement sauf
contre indication médicale
alors si vladimir poutine voulait rendre
la vaccination obligatoire il le
pourrait il ferait voter une nouvelle
loi à la douma
mais manifestement ce n'est pas le cas
et ce tient à ce que les choses soit
injuste et localement par les autorités
locales
peut-être aussi faire porter assez
largement la responsabilité sur ces
autorités locales alors la vaccination
le porte parole du kremlin
curieusement a dit hier que ne serait
pas possible d'atteindre l'immunité à
l'automne tue c'est à dire de la
vaccination de 60% de la population se
serait il faudrait un temps plus long
probablement
la fin de l'année le dossier ukrainien
comme le disait verra également au menu
de ce grand oral et avec le président
volodymyr zelensky vladimir poutine a
réagi à quoi bon nous rencontrer le
dialogue est pour ainsi dire ont pu
alors il n'y a pas beaucoup d'appétit
pour rencontrer et volodymyr zelensky cv
moins que l'on puisse dire puis
rencontre est cependant son prédécesseur
le président porochenko qui avaient des
positions pro-occidentales puisqu'après
tout c'est pour hoshiko qui a fait
inscrire dans la constitution que
l'ukraine devrait rentrer dans l'otan
chacun sait que pour vladimir poutine
c'est une ligne rouge et il a d'ailleurs
signifié à joe biden la semaine dernière
à genève
alors quels sont les les défauts de
monsieur et 20 ce qui aux yeux du
président russe
il est possible que ce soit le fait que
en effet la campagne contre la langue
russe se poursuit en ukraine et que
volodymyr 1 et l'ins qui ne se bat pas
pour faire reconnaître le russe la
langue et la culture russes comme une
langue et une culture minoritaire à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine
c'est un point qui pourtant pourrait
être être discuté par le président russe
et par le président ukrainien
monsieur poutine a dit clairement qu'il
ne voulait pas discuter avec et l'ins
qui bien sûr de la crimée mais pas du
donbass non plus puisque le nom de basse
c'est quelque chose qui relève de
l'application des accords de minsk et
que ces accords on sait que les
interprétations que vladimir poutine
leur donne il faut que monsieur et nas
qui discute avec les autorités de fait
de louhansk et de dawn est à la fois du
régime d'autonomie et des conditions de
déroulement des élections dans ces deux
provinces et monsieur nm ce qui ne veut
pas le faire dans les conditions
actuelles il voudrait d'abord qui
récupère est le contrôle de la frontière
avec la russie ce qui n'est pas
acceptable pour moscou où on en est
toujours là et il est possible que
monsieur est inscrit et monsieur poutine
se rencontrent dans quelques mois
mais monsieur poutine veut clairement
établir que ce serait pour discuter des
relations
si on entre kiev et moscou est pas du
nom basse et évidemment on le disait
aussi un la relation avec les états unis
après la rencontre à genève entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine les réponses
aujourd'hui du président russe sur sa
relation avec les américains qui indique
une détente amorcée
alors je crois que son explication est
une explication à destination du grand
public russe
voilà les américains continuent à se
comporter comme la plus grande puissance
mondiale
alors qu'ils sont menacés sur ce plan
par la chine mais tous les observateurs
s'accordent à reconnaître que la semaine
dernière à genève
joe biden a fait une avancée importante
en direction de la russie en lui
reconnaissant qu' elle était l'intérieur
stratégiques nucléaires naturel des
états unis pour la bonne raison que les
deux pays détiennent 90% des têtes
nucléaires et des missiles pour les
délivrer par conséquent ils ont la
responsabilité de l'absence d'une guerre
nucléaire et de la stabilité mondiale
sur ce point mais joe biden a avancé un
nouveau point qui est le point de la
cyberguerre il a très clairement dit à
vladimir poutine que si des objectifs
stratégiques civils ou militaires
étaient atteints aux états unis et bien
il y aurait des représailles
avec des moyens beaucoup plus puissant
autrement dit pour les états unis
aujourd'hui
la cyberguerre devient quelque chose qui
est important parce qu'on ne sait pas
quelles sont les règles de la dissuasion
dans la cyber-guerre pour le moment il
n'y a pas de dissuasion et que c'est par
ce biais d'une attaque cyber attribué à
l'êta avec ou sans preuve
en tout cas quelques fois avec des
présomptions des représailles des
représailles aux représailles et par
conséquent une escalade dans laquelle on
pourrait se diriger vers un véritable
conflit est le deuxième groupe de
travail qui a été convenu à genève
et précisément destinée à traiter de ce
sujet quelles règles peloton peut-on
établir dans ce domaine d'autant plus
que les cyber attaques peuvent être
faites par des état relativement peu
puissant et il s'agit pas uniquement les
états unis de la russie l'un comme
l'autre peuvent être victimes
tata que cyber et peut-être vous
retrouvez un intérêt commun à s'en
protéger
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales et semaine en
de mobilisation internationale en
solidarité avec le co fondateur de
wikileaks julian assange en événements
l'initiative de la fiancée de lanceurs
d'alerté de nombreux soutiens
objectif dénoncer à nouveau la détention
de julian assange jugées arbitraires les
détails avec série est beau un
anniversaire
derrière les barreaux ce samedi le co
fondateur de wikileaks julian assange
fêtera ses 50 ans dans la prison de
belmarsh à londres pour cette semaine
particulière ses soutiens ont organisé
une campagne nommée assange week afin de
dénoncer sa détention alors que le frère
et le père du lanceur d'alert font
actuellement campagne en sa faveur aux
états unis sa compagne se mobilisent au
royaume uni pour rappeler la situation
du journaliste à l'opinion publique
chaque fois que je vois je vienne ici
c'est difficile de vraiment comprendre
comment tout ça peut encore durer
julien est un prisonnier politique au
royaume uni il est incarcéré depuis plus
de deux ans et il aura 50 ans samedi
la dernière fois que julian a été un
homme libre il avait la trentaine
il avait 39 ans lorsqu'il est venu dans
ce pays sur invitation du guardian ce
mardi elle est venue manifester devant
la prison de belles marches accompagné
de parlementaires travaillistes
britanniques plus de 20 membres du
parlement ont signé une lettre à
l'attention du directeur de la prison
ils exigent de rencontres et de julian
assange nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour
attirer l'attention sur le fait que nous
vrillon pouvoir rendre visite à julian
et prendre conseil auprès de lui en tant
que membre élu de notre parlement
jusqu'à présent cela nous a été refusé
mais nous allons continuer à le demander
mais plus que tout poursuivons cette
campagne et veillons à ce que julian ne
soit pas tout bonnement extradé vers les
états unis ou ailleurs mais qu'ils
soient libérés afin qu'ils puissent être
avec sa compagne ses enfants et être à
nouveau en homme libre
julian assange est incarcéré depuis
avril 2019
d'abord à la demande de la justice
suédoise puis des états unis qui
l'accusent d'avoir diffusé des documents
classifiés sur des activités militaires
américaines
il risque une peine de 100 75 ans de
prison s'il est extradé en janvier
dernier la justice britannique a annoncé
son refus de l'expulser outre atlantique
une décision contestée par
l'administration biden qui a fait appel
au mois de février
le cofondateur de wikileaks reste depuis
dans l'attenté de la décision de la cour
d'appel et aux etats-unis visite
attendue ce soir de donald trump au
mexique avec le gouverneur du texas
nouveau retour sur le devant de la scène
pour l'ex-président américain après son
discours aux allures de campagne
d'attendre la mi-mandat de la semaine
dernière dans l'ohio robin pelle
l'immigration s'invite dans le débat
public aux états unis à l'origine de
cette nouvelle séquence le retour de
donald trump sur la scène politique ce
week-end
plus d'un an avant les élections de mi
mandat l'occasion pour l'ancien
président de critiquer la politique de
son successeur à la maison blanche sur
cette question pendant son mandat
le républicain en avait fait l'une de
ses priorités en adoptant une ligne dure
à l'occasion d'un meeting dans l'ohio ce
samedi donald trump a rappelé ses
ambitions en la matière lorsqu'un
étranger en situation irrégulière
franchissaient la frontière nous la
trappe ion le mettions en détention et
le châssis ont rapidement notre pays par
milliers
depuis des semaines les responsables
républicains critiquent la politique de
l'administration byden le printemps a
été marqué par des arrestations massives
à la frontière sud des états unis joe
biden a chargé kamala harris de
l'épineux dossier de l'immigration
clandestine
la vice-présidente américaine s'est
rendue vendredi dernier dans les zones
concernées
une visite pour se rendre compte de la
situation sur le terrain nous avons
examiné un système dans lequel des
personnes ont été logées dans des
conditions inhumaines au cours des
dernières années un système d'asile qui
a été brisée et qui doit être
reconstruit et en cinq mois nous avons
fait des progrès mais il reste encore
beaucoup de travail à faire mais nous
avons fait des progrès malgré ses
promesses de campagne
joe biden ne parvient pas à mettre en
place une politique opposée à celle de
donald trump
on met 180 mille personnes ont été
interpellées après avoir traversé
clandestinement la frontière entre le
mexique et les etats unis un record
depuis plus de 15 ans donald trump qui
avait déchiré en mai 2010huit l'accord
de vienne sur le nucléaire iranien alors
qu'un nouveau round de négociations est
prévue ces prochains jours pour un
retour des etats unis dans le texte le
secrétaire général de l'onu appelle
aujourd'hui à lever les sanctions
imposées à téhéran sous l'administration
trump et 15 membres du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies doivent se
réunir marne et sur cette question
j'appelle les états unis à lever les
sanctions mentionné dans le plan je
continue de croire qu'une restauration
complète du plan reste le meilleur moyen
de garantir que le programme nucléaire
de la république islamique d'iran sera
exclusivement pacifique reste arthuis
également aujourd'hui du futur ex
président iranien à sanaa rohani
toujours en exercice en attendant la
prise de fonction officielle de son
successeur ebrahim raïssi appelle son
homologue américain joe biden à
respecter l'une de ses promesses de
campagne
la nouvelle administration qui a pris
ses fonctions aux états unis a déclaré
dans sa campagne électorale que trump
avait mal agi
c'est très important avant que les gens
ne votent pour ce gouvernement
en nommant joe biden a dit que c'était
la mauvaise voie et les gens ont voté
pour le nouveau gouvernement avec la
même idée et la même opinion aujourd'hui
sibide néglige la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord de vienne sur le nucléaire
iranien
il trahit ses propres vote heleven de sa
propre nation parce que les gens sont
venus voter sur cette base il est élu
sur la base qu'il allait lever les
sanctions et réparer cette faute sur le
qui-vive face à l'avancée des talibans
sur le territoire des tensions
persistent dans la région longtemps
occupé par l'armée américaine qui a
annoncé leur retraite ces troubles ici
le 11 septembre prochain soit vingt ans
après l'invasion du pays
un retrait qui laisse le peuple afghan
face à une très grande instabilité au
risque d'une nouvelle guerre civile le
point avec yamina baïda à quel d'art
dans le nord du pays
à quelques pas de l'ouzbékistan et du
tadjikistan c'est armé que les forces
gouvernementales associées à des milices
avance à la recherche des talibans les
traces du passage des insurgés sont
encore visibles
comme vous le voyez c'est une maison
privée
les talibans sont venus et ont creusé
chaque murs des maisons dont le but d'y
pénétrer dans cette zone
regardez voici un endroit où les
talibans ont attaqué à l'armé lourde
nous sommes arrivés ici vers 6h hier
alors que le quartier général de la
sécurité et le district été capturé par
les talibans
le bazar du district a également été
capturé par les talibans qui nous ont
combattu pendant deux heures et non pas
pu nous vaincre ce qui les a poussés à
se retirer
les talibans se serait emparé de plus de
40 district ces dernières semaines au
total 163 district sur 400 seraient
contrôlées par les talibans il existe
d'autres districts dont seul le centre
et détenu par l'administration de kaboul
mais les zones environnantes sont sous
notre contrôle
donc on le calcule en tous ces plus de
80% du territoire qui est tenu par nos
forces
prise en étau dans ce conflit meurtrier
les familles menacées quittent leur
domicile cela fait environ 3 4 jours que
nous dormons ici sur le sol et mes
enfants qui sont ici aussi
enfin n'ont pas d'eau potable et pas de
nourriture à manger nous dormons dans ce
froid et cela fait deux jours que nous
n'avons ni nourriture ni eau nous ne
recevons que des dîners il n'y a plus
rien à manger
notre maison a été bombardées et
détruites et j'ai été déplacées mon mari
a été martyrisé j'espère que le
gouvernement me donnera une maison de la
nourriture ils doivent nous donner un
abri
ces attaques de taliban lieu alors que
le retrait progressif de l'armée
américaine et de l'otan se poursuit
mardi l'allemagne a déclaré que ses
troupes avaient quitté le pays
même annonce le lendemain de la part de
l'italie particulièrement engagés sur
place avec 50 mille militaires déployés
en 20 ans selon le pentagone
un accord de paix est nécessaire pour
remettre de l'ordre dans le pays
la violence reste trop élevé et nous
sommes tous conscients de la situation
sécuritaire en afghanistan
ce que nous aimerions voir c'est le
retour des talibans dont le processus de
paix d'une manière crédible et à mesure
que nous voyons les événements sur le
terrain se dérouler
cela remet certainement en question la
sincérité de leurs efforts pour être un
participant légitime et crédible au
processus de paix c'est vraiment le bon
avenir pour l'afghanistan
un processus positif qui mène à un
règlement négocié et à une fin pacifique
des combats en afghanistan les
etats-unis ont annoncé leur intention
d'achever le retrait des troupes
américaines engagées en afghanistan
d'ici le 11 septembre prochain aux états
unis où un rapport accablant également
pour la défense française a été publiée
par une société américaine après avoir à
passer en revue les capacités militaires
françaises le constat est sévère en plus
de précision on retrouve notre reporter
thomas bonnet en direct de washington
bonsoir thomas cap quand on au juste
dans ce rapport
bonsoir stéphanie effectivement c'est un
rapport plutôt sévère contre la défense
militaire française un rapport qui est
délivrée par une un think tank américain
qui s'appelle wang corporacion qui est
une organisation plutôt respecté pour
ses analyses ici aux etats unis une
organisation qui se présente comme
indépendante et apolitique mais ce
rapport le rapport en question a été
commandée par le pentagone et il a donc
évidemment une portée politique
quand on va sur laquelle on va on va
revenir un peu plus tard en tout cas il
est donc très sévère pour les forces
militaires françaises notamment en cas
de conflit de haute intensité sur un
front à l'est de l'europe évidemment
tout cela n'est pas choisi au hasard la
france serait dit le rapport un allié
solide aux capacités limitées voilà pour
le constat sans appel
en cause notamment le manque de
ressources notamment le manque de
munitions dans l'est dans l'armée
française écouter le premier extrait de
ce rapport dans un premier temps les
militaires français pourrait sans doute
être en mesure de remplir toutes les
missions mais il manque de profondeur à
savoir que des opérations aussi
exigeante et puis très rapidement ses
ressources humaines et matérielles et
thomas pour tirer ce bilan ce film tant
qu'américain qui envisage un scénario
particulier puisque il part du principe
qu'une guerre éclate entre eux l'anru si
tiens donc et des pays européens
soutenus par les états unis
absolument un scénario qui n'a
évidemment pas été choisi au hasard il
s'agit donc dans le scénario qui a été
choisi par ce think tank d'une guerre de
haute intensité sur un front à l'est de
l'europe entre les pays alliés de l'otan
les pays européens soutenus donc par les
états unis
on retrouve en réalité le même
storytelling qui est utilisé très
régulièrement par l'otan écoutez un
extrait de ce rapport justement pour
bien saisir comment est présentée la
russie dans le texte
les alliés pourraient se trouver dans
une situation dans laquelle les forces
terrestres serait fortement surclassé en
effectifs et en matériel par les moyens
que la russie pourrait déployer en une
semaine ou deux aux frontières des états
baltes
voilà donc la rhétorique utilisée dans
ce rapport qui colle en réalité à celle
utilisée par l'otan par le pentagone et
plus généralement par les autorités
militaires américaines
donc par rapport à la russie alors il ya
plusieurs analyses qu'on peut faire de
ce document d'une part peut-être que
l'administration militaire française
pourra tirer quelques conclusions de ce
rapport encore une fois assez sévère
avec l'armée française même s'il faut
dire que le pilote a été tiré a été
effectuée en 2018 et que depuis des
mesures ont été prises notamment dans la
loi de programmation militaire en france
et puis surtout l'analyse qu'on peut
faire de ce rapport c'est que bien que
le think tank en question se présente
comme apolitique et indépendante
finalement son discours sert
complètement celui du pentagone à savoir
donc que les pays alliés de l'otan ont
tout intérêt à y rester a participé à
son financement et c'est finalement ce
qu'on avait déjà entendu dans les propos
de joe biden et d'anthony blinken lors
de leurs voyages respectifs en europe en
agitant de manière à céret manière
régulière la menace russe avec donc la
menace d'un potentiel conflit entre
l'europe et la russie et bien il
justifie le fait que ces pays ne doivent
absolument pas quitter l'otan merci
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
restait avec ton marque une courte pause
dans quelques instants nous parlerons
des jardins les
dans le xviiie arrondissement de paris
occupé depuis plusieurs semaines par des
toxicomanes ils ont été évacués la nuit
dernière une première réponse à des
riverains excédés et puis nous
reviendrons sur l'insomnie de lusine
lubrizol en septembre 2019 la cour
d'appel de paris confirme la mise en
examen de la société américaine
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent pour l
on soit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
toulepleu moins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes ne bouleverse
nous bouleverse toujours vous savez
parce qu'on les comprend pas il nous
touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est c'est quoi c'est de
faire de la pédagogie c'est de faire
mieux que ça c'est de recréer des liens
que la politique n'arrive plus à rené
malo c'est à dire que la culture c'est
au dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit
des vérités que nous disent personne ni
les politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni
les journalistes et nous sommes sereins
c'est la même culture c'est la même
façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
tout est pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir et
aliments
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe nous sommes à chez
vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
fois leurs procédés en 2011 le monde
manque pas un petit peu non ah oui c'est
tous les fromages tous les soucis sont
toutes les les croissants la pâtisserie
traits de caractère des russes qui te
plaît l'amitié les gens les gens très
stylé fallu les français ne savent pas
je ne le pensais jamais de ma vie faire
la plonge et autonomie vous pouvez me
souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
monsieur les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france c'est chacun
pour soi dieu pour tous cet écho
politique n'a jamais été obligé de dire
la vérité d idée courageuse des mots qui
comptent
elle conçoit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche plus titré dans
ce musée de la ténacité
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez à paris les
toxicomanes désormais interdite d'accès
aux jardins d'eole située dans le
nord-est de la capitale la maire de
paris anne hidalgo s'était engagé à
rendre cet espace aux riverains dc est
la fin du mois de juin jusqu'à présent
les toxicomanes y avait des taxes et
jusqu'à tard dans la nuit
suscitant ainsi la colère et
l'exaspération de nombreux ivrin qui se
sont justement rassemblés ce soir et
c'est el farj avec charles godric c'est
leur septième rassemblement depuis le 19
mai ces riverains du quartier de
stalingrad se rassemblent chaque
mercredi
ici devant le jardin d'eole pour alerter
sur la situation de leur quartier car
c'est ici dans ce parc que de nombreux
toxicomanes la plupart des pendants au
crack avait pour habitude de se
regrouper
anne hidalgo s'était engagé à rendre ce
jardin aux riverains avant la fin du
mois de juin
cette nuit des agents de la ville de
paris est accompagné de membres des
forces de l'ordre et de médiateurs ont
donc évacuer les toxicomanes du jardin
le parc n'est désormais accessibles que
par une seule porte alors qu'il
rencontre 3 et ce afin de contrôler les
entrées des activités dites positives
sont en train d'être déployé une ferme
urbaine mais aussi des buvettes ou
encore des espaces de jeu un premier pas
pour ces riverains qui vont donc
redécouvrir leur jardin sous un autre
jour mais ils vont tout de même
continuer à se mobiliser car pour eux le
problème a juste été déplacé ce qu'ils
demandent
ce sont de réels dispositif pour prendre
en charge ces toxicomanes
on n'en peut plus les hôtels sociaux
sont totalement autonome il ya des
vendeurs de craquer des consommateurs de
crack et des toxicomanes voire même des
passes qui s'y passe là bas ils repèrent
les appartements ils vont essayer de les
fracasser il ya un comportement criminel
en continu on ne sait plus quoi faire
est ce que le parisien doit se comporter
comme marc matraque et se faire justice
lui-même contre les toxicomanes ou est
ce que la police va prendre ses
responsabilités et faire et faire des
actes concrets
parce que on ne peut plus on ne peut
plus il faut donner des moyens aussi
les policiers souffrent et il faut
donner les moyens on voit aux policiers
il faut que la justice sont beaucoup
plus sévères
nous demandons
nous faisons depuis bientôt sept
semaines au gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités de regarder ce que nos
voisins européens le font depuis plus de
30 ans et enfin de mettre sur pied une
politique ambitieuse et surtout
transpartisane c'est à dire qu'il ne
soit pas dépendante de d'une quelconque
élection c'est à dire que c'est un
problème de santé publique
l'évacuation du jardin ne suffit donc
pas à apaiser les inquiétudes des
riverains anne hidalgo s'est rendu ce
matin sur place
elle a assuré avoir demandé à l'état de
travailler sur la mise en place de
plusieurs lieux de prise en charge
thérapeutique des toxicomanes si ces
propositions ne sont pas suivies d'effet
eh bien nous prendrons nos
responsabilités et nous ouvrirons des
lieux avec des médecins avec des
psychiatres avec des infirmiers et des
infirmières avec les associations de je
salue et donc nous aurons la mise en
place de ce type de lieu ici aussi à
paris donc si l'état ne prend pas ses
responsabilités nous les prendrons
le retour à la normale pour les
habitants de ce quartier ne semble pas
tout à fait d'actualité si pour le
moment les riverains ne savent pas s'ils
vont poursuivre ou non les
rassemblements ils vont tout de même
continuer de se mobiliser tant qu'un
plan ambitieux de lutte contre la
toxicomanie de ruches ne sera pas
concrètement mise en place et pour se
sortir de l'emprise du crack la seule
solution serait de quitter paris écouter
ce témoignage de didier consommateurs de
crack qui comme de nombreuses demandes à
pouvoir être mis au vert c'est que
jamais vos réussira à faire parce que
tout ce monde là
donc c'est qu'il veut vraiment un leader
celoni
ouais partir couloir à plus de 100
kilomètres de pavés cccc le mieux à
faire est a que ça à faire je regrette
d'être venu ici ne vous ment pas c'est
mon pire cauchemar si paris a savais pas
que ça allait ça allait se passer comme
ça tu es insatisfaits en fait à cette
fois il t'en fous oui il va y venir il
va donner quelque chose de pur au début
pour que ces les cadeaux qui font aimer
c'est ça qui va te donner envie de ouais
il est beau il est bon est ce que tu vas
venir acheter avec ton argent ça sera m
toutes les fois disent simplement a été
dit on va faire la manche vous voulez
tant qu'etat temps et pour en parler
nous sommes avec frédéric français le
porte parole du collectif 19 bonsoir
frédéric française merci d'être avec
nous on vous a souvent eu un ici sur
cette antenne vous étiez exaspéré
aujourd'hui quel est votre état d'esprit
après cette évacuation du jardin et hall
alors on n'est plus du tout exaspéré là
maintenant on est complètement désabusés
parce que effectivement on attendait
avec beaucoup d'impatience et beaucoup
d'espérance leu leu
village du jardin mais on s'attendait
peut-être parce que les toxicomanes soit
pris en charge
qu'ils soient pas laissés en errance
autour du jardin et enfin te saouler des
sous le nez des riverains là clairement
en fait on est complètement désabusé et
relativement énervé parce que en fait on
a l'impression de s'être fait prendre un
petit peu pour des imbéciles par la
mairie qui nous a fait des réunions
pendant un certain temps mais qui nous
anime donc effectivement le jardin
serait évacuée par contre on s'attendait
à ce que vraiment ils soient pris en
charge les toxicomanes que les dealers
se fait arrêter par la police
et c'est vrai que le premier jour 2 du
dispositif n'a pas donner réellement les
effets escomptés
ça veut dire quoi concrètement c'est que
tout simplement ces toxicomanes sont
sont déplacés ils ont été évacués vers
quoi vert ou aujourd'hui pour bien qu'on
comprenne
alors qui se passe et qui n'ont pas du
tout été évacués en réalité ce qui s'est
passé c'est que hier soir le jardin
fermé à une heure du matin puisque ils
lisent étaient autorisés à y rester
jusqu'à une heure du matin jusqu'à hier
soir donc à une heure du matin le parc
fermé
la police a essayé de les disperser vers
une heure du matin parce que bon voilà
ils sont toujours devant les l'avenue
riquet devant l'entrée de leur ferry
quai et ce matin donc à 10 heures du
matin le la mairie n'a ouvert qu'une
seule entrée et à filtrer l'entrée
donc ils ont empêché les toxicomanes
d'entrer dans le parc en revanche aucune
solution n'a été trouvée pour les
toxicomanes on parle d'évacuation n'y a
pas eu d'évacuation à proprement parler
il ya eu juste en fait une ombre un
empêchement des toxicomanes d'entrer
dans le parc en réalité
voilà ils sont en errance dans les rues
ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes donc ils ne
sont plus dans le parc effectivement ils
sont autour du parc dans les rues
adjacentes au pied des immeubles dans
les parkings il ya vu déjà en fait des
gros problème aujourd'hui dans le
quartier saint lô très triste dans tout
ça c'est que les riverains la population
parisienne évidemment empathie mais on a
vu dans ce témoignage poignant que les
toxicomanes sont désespérés aussi ce
monsieur évoqué son pire cauchemar et
que selon lui jamais ils n'arriveront à
nous déloger d'ici tous
ils demandent même une mise au vert loin
de paris c'est une situation qui semble
inextricable
alors tout à fait c'est un petit peu
compliqué parce que il ya deux doctrines
qui sait qu'ils proposent c'est la
doctrine je dirais de la mairie de paris
qui est des médecins qui veulent
absolument passer par des salles de
consommation à moindre risque par un
encadrement de la consommation et une
diminution progressive et ce qui se
passe c'est que les toxicomanes de même
qu'ils sont donc des malades les
patients eux-mêmes dire je dirais en
fait on pas du tout envie d'avoir une à
un arrêt progressif ou en accompagnement
de la consommation ce qu'ils veulent
c'est arrêter totalement la drogue donc
si ça pose un petit souci parce qu'on a
vu déjà sur le rapport de l'inserm qui a
été publié en début d'année qu'il y
avait en fait une divergence réel entre
ce qui est préconisé par les médecins et
par la mairie est ce que souhaite
réellement les toxicomanes donc sacré en
fait vraiment un énorme écart et du coup
on ne sait plus vraiment où on fait
comment faire quoi pour traiter ces gens
ce qu'on voudrait c'est qu'il soit
encadré effectivement après nombre des
structures qui nous paraissent nous
hospitalière sais c'est qu'il leur faut
c'est une structure où il sera encadré
de façon ferme et je dirais pour que à
partir du moment où ils consacrent à
rentrer dans le processus d'arrêt de la
drogue ils puissent être encadrés
soigner et surtout qui rechute pas donc
effectivement peut-être les éloigner de
paris ça peut être une solution
j'ai eu récemment une merde une
toxicomane qui m'a appelé et qui m'a
confirmé qu'effectivement le seul moyen
pour sa fille d'arrêter réellement la
drogue c'était 2
de quitter paris nous revenir chez ses
parents par contre ses parents en fait
on a un gros problème c'est que quand il
essaye de la faire soigner donc par les
moyens légaux je dirais donc il faut
passer il faut quatre à cinq jours a
appelé différents services pour pouvoir
arriver à ce que cette personne soit
donc prise en charge par les hôpitaux
par contre et c'est ce qu'elle mexique
et cette maman c'est que les toxicomanes
ensuite ne peuvent très bien de
ressortir aussi vite de l'hôpital c'est
à dire qu'elle a passé cinq jours à
essayer de la faire rentrer dans
l'hôpital et 24 heures après elle était
déjà sorti parce qu'il n'ya pas de
surveillance etc les scellés les
hôpitaux ne sont pas fermées et c'est
vraiment ça qui est un problème c'est il
faut vraiment que cette semaine soit
encadré et elle ne se puisse pas sortir
du lieu de soins parce que sinon elle
retourne directement voir les dealers et
vont re consommer clairement aujourd'hui
on sent une impuissance de de l'état lui
même chacun se renvoie la balle à la
mairie de paris le gouvernement
la honte on ne vous rassurer en disant
pour éviter de nouveaux rassemblements
dans la zone de stalingrad
on va renforcer la présence policière ça
semble absurde on c'est un début de
solution pour vous pour nous c'est juste
absurde en fait la pole la présence
policière tout ce que ça fait c'est
déplacer le problème
les policiers ne sont pas là pour en
prendre en charge les toxicomanes et ils
peuvent pas les soigner tout ce qu'ils
peuvent faire c'est éventuellement donc
est déplacé leur demander de ne pas
rester ne vous aime pas consommer en
fait dans la rue éventuellement arrêter
les dealers mais il faudrait vraiment
c'est de retrouver à ces toxicomanes à
une solution de repli
il faut qu'ils puissent être encadrés
dans un lieu en dehors de paris ou en
dehors en tout cas d
les riverains relativement loin des
riverains dans une zone industrielle par
exemple pour qu'ils soient en fait pris
en charge plus que plus pauvres plus
simplement voilà de manière plus
efficace parce que là actuellement ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est les disperser dans
les rues et du cou avant c'était le
jardin qui était infréquentable
maintenant c'est tout l'arrondissement
qui va devenir infréquentable puisque
les 400 personnes n'ont pas disparu
elles sont justes en errance dans les
rues et elles sont très dangereuses a
priori merci en tout cas frédéric france
elle porte parole du collectif 19
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france en france là le jugement de la
cour d'appel de paris concernant le
recours de lusine lubrizol est tombé il
confirme la mise en examen la société
après l incendie d'euros en 2019 pour
les dégâts environnementaux
les détails avec notre reporter mona
amont dès lors c'est un ouf de
soulagement pour les victimes la cour
d'appel de paris confirme la mise en
examen de lubrizol et rejette donc la
requête en nullité déposée par la
multinationale lubrizol devra donc faire
face à deux chefs d'inculpation
déversement de substances nuisibles dans
les eaux naturelles et exploitation non
conforme ayant porté atteinte grave à la
santé la sécurité ou l'environnement
lubrizol contestait cette procédure
estimant qu'il y avait eu des
irrégularités et mettait en cause
l'impartialité des inspecteurs qui
avaient constaté des infractions
majeures suite à l' incendie 9500 tonnes
de produits chimiques avaient été
déversés dans la nature
plus de 500 riverains avaient déposé
plainte après le passage d'un nuage de
fumée provoqué par l'incendié
beaucoup de riverains se plaignaient de
maux de tête et de nausées
la décision de la justice va donc
permettre l'ouverture d'un procès c'est
une première victoire pour les victimes
et pour en parler nous sommes avec sinon
de carvalho président de l'association
des sinistrés de lubrizol bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous on imagine
effectivement que c'est une première
victoire comme l'a dit et monaco dès
lors vous devez être satisfait de ce
rejet de la cour d'appel de paris
oui bonsoir oui nous sommes très
heureuses un premier pas vers la
condamnation aussi des gens qui très
bonne nouvelle le prononcé avec
précaution en mars et encore pour
beaucoup travaillé
du travail à faire en tout cas ce que
vous espérez c'est certainement une
condamnation et un procès au pénal c'est
aussi l'enjeu de ce rejet il y aura bel
et bien un procès au pénal de de la
société du brésil il ya assez d'éléments
qui démontrent que les dirigeants de
cette usine avait tous les éléments pour
voir d'éviter cette catastrophe
c'est mon père et environnement sauf
qu'ils n'ont rien fait vous avez les
informations de la part des services de
la part de leurs assureurs et les avait
plus et donc oui sont pénalement falloir
tirer le responsable alors il ya eu des
négligences flagrante de la part de
l'entreprise selon vous est-ce que
c'était une négligence coupable ou ou
une négligence ma foi d'inattention est
ce que je veux dire par là pardonnez moi
c est ce que il y a de la volonté il y
avait un acte volontaire en tout cas on
a laissé faire malgré wii avait beaucoup
trop de dysfonctionnements déjà
lorsqu'on envoie nos pompiers sur le
lieu et qu'il n'y a aucun moyen pour il
je sais si c'est inadmissible donc c'est
plein d'éléments comme ça qui font que
le danger est l'arrivée donc il le
savait très bien
donc si on veut que les choses ou genre
en france si on veut vraiment que les
entreprises respectent l'environnement
et notre santé à nous evra qui habite au
juste il va falloir effectivement mené
des dossiers au pénal ou pas hésité à
construire des dossiers juridiques elle
est à monter les collectifs et des
associations pour aller au pénal et à
l'ailé très dur ce qui retient
l'attention c'est mon vélo c'est que
cette mise en examen elle est sûre les
dégâts environnementaux mais mais pas
sur la mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
est ce que ce qualificatif manque selon
vous clairement jeunes évidemment
ramuz trouvé ce avait fait face à un
danger qui est impossible parce que on
parle de deux cancers de maladies
futures
évidemment à l'instant ting lu par
immédiate mais on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de ça on sait très bien que
il va y avoir des maladies donc et ça va
arriver dans quelques années
donc il faut se préparer nous c'est que
cette catastrophe sanitaire qui va
arriver
nous espérons que le juge d'entendre a
ainsi façon nous sommes partis pour une
longue procédure
donc nous croisons les doigts pour
éviter d'avoir une catastrophe sanitaire
mais il faut s'y préparer
vu des substances qui ont volé vu le
tonnage aussi est autant d'expositions
et nous avons dû quand même envie d'un
homme fait face à des odeurs au chili
qui a des problèmes de santé liés à
cette usine à la décontamination de ces
piscines
donc il y aura forcément des séquelles
sur leur santé et toute façon notre
environnement et notre santé
ce que l'on mange ce que l'on voit donc
s'il ya une atteinte à l'environnement
il ya forcément inintéressant donc nous
nous en tant qu'association victimes
à nous aussi d'apporter les éléments au
juge
l'écart à chaque cas est particulier les
avons tous des problèmes de santé
différent
il ya des rapports qui commencent à
émerger
mais c'est un peu trop timides ont fait
appel aux médecins spécialistes afin
qu'ils s'organisent aussi fort qu'on
soit pas seul dans l'eau qu'ils aident
les associations victims il votre
collègue secrétaire de l'union des
victimes de lubrizol christoph hohl vie
lui il appelle carrément à faire changer
les lois il dit depuis napoléon on
protège la chimie tant qu'il n'y aura
pas de vraie sanction comme des
fermetures administratives et bien les
accidents industriels se multiplieront
avons partagé ce technique alors
évidemment que dans cette affaire il ya
le droit de l'environnement
mais quinze mille euros damende pour une
entreprise comme lubrizol c'est comme si
vous étiez au volant de votre voiture
que vous griller un feu rouge et que la
police mais qu un centime d'euros
d'amendé
ce que vous pensez que la prochaine fois
vous êtes précise et ans
vous allez peut-être pas hésité à
griller le feu rouge 15 centimes d'euros
d'amendé bien que c'est pas suffisant
pour ces entreprises c'est pareil c'est
insuffisant dans le pénal par contre là
si on commence à prendre la
responsabilité individuelle de ces
dirigeants là peut-être qu'on pourra
faire changer les choses mais il est
clair que il ya un vide juridique à
toutes les guerres que les entreprises
les industriels ofit polluent à tout va
vraiment ils préfèrent pollué que de
mettre aux normes que deux rendez compte
que pour le moment cette usine à la
toucher une prime d'assurance contre 91
millions d'euros
pendant que nous victimes on n'a même
pas on n'a rien perçu
madut avancer de l'argent on a dû payer
nos traitements et y est allé franchises
d'assurances etc etc
et puis le tranquille 91 millions
d'euros
et c'est sûrement qu'un premier
versement donc vraiment me demande si
pas une incitation à la pollution
il faut vraiment que l'état veille et
que nous citoyens nous veillons si voilà
il faut agir
c'était ma prochaine question il ya la
justice bien sûr le recours à la justice
que vous êtes en train de faire mais
enfin vu la gravité de la situation à ce
que vous en avait appelé aux pouvoirs
publics aux autorités et si oui que vous
vous at on répondu
ben comme d'habitude un agence régionale
de santé isss en équipe de france sont
les grands absents vous rendez compte
que nous sommes dans une attente d'un
suivi sanitaire et que juste pour et
pour rendre publique une enquête de
satisfaction sur le ressenti de la
catastrophe
on devrait attendre et nous l'attendons
toujours donc soit disant elle doit
sortie mais oui
l'urgence où est l'urgence c'est
pourquoi nous en tant que associations
on souhaite place un institut est
possible par à-coups comme il en existe
à fos-sur-mer un institut indépendant
qui sera géré par des citoyens afin
d'éveiller et d'agir rapidement
lorsqu'il y aura une catastrophe comme
il y en a trop souvent
merci beaucoup sinon de carvalho d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rtl
on sait rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du coc vide
chaque vaccination est une protection
contre une nouvelle vague prévient
gabriela talent alors que la menace
d'une quatrième vague plane en raison de
la progression du variant delta et puis
reviendront sur le débat qui a agité des
députés hier soir faut-il interdire aux
assesseurs de porter un voile
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terres rares sont au coeur des défis
du 21e si c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les pays puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve
mondiale est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines terreur il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une des plus importantes
compagnies de taxis en france l'activité
a repris sdap elmander paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour là l'avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
garé ya qu à 5-6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivé là
concurrents les vtc gros gros choc
d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé les 20000 à
45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental on est tous
conscients que le football ligny tout ce
qui est au niveau social surtout au
niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en entend
tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
boire les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et nantes surtout au niveau au niveau
football et ça c'est touchant
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière ce qu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues qui avait
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
feront normalement les cellules
sensibles à la lumière dans la rétine
parce qu'il va dire qu'il voit un pc il
distingue la lumière il distingue quoi
exactement
alors le patient avec le pain par
exemple de reconnaître les passages
protégés dans la rue de détecter des
objets différents objets de petite
taille de grande taille plusieurs
niveaux en page 2 les comptes et de les
attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années qui est déjà une source
d'espoir c'est évidemment pas un point
définitif du parcours c'est un rude
étape franchie
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 30 juin
chaque vaccination est une protection
contre une nouvelle vague déclaration de
gabriella talent alors que jean castex
lui a annoncé qu'il allait lancer dans
les jours qui viennent une consultation
autour de la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants dans les landes le
déconfinement est lui suspendu jusqu'au
6 juillet en raison du variant delta le
reste de l'hexagone voilà levée des
dernières contrainte et la fin des jo
faut-il interdire aux assesseurs de
porter un voile le débat déchaîné les
passions et hier soir dans l'hémicycle
autour d'un amendement émanant du modem
est finalement rejetée si l'obligation
de neutralité religieuse ne concerne que
les présidents et président de bureau
pote le sujet reste clivant alors menace
pour la laïcité une victoire de
l'intégration ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face
le liban s'enfonce dans la crise des
gens croient aux pénuries les prix des
carburants ont grimpé de 30% selon la
banque mondiale le pays du cèdre fait
face à l'une des pires crises
économiques mondiales depuis plus d'un
siècle
venus a de son côté annoncé que la
moitié la population vivait désormais
sous le seuil de pauvreté
[Musique]
et face notamment l'inquiétude liée aux
variants delta jean castex a donc
annoncé qu'il allait lancer dans les
jours qui viennent une consultation
autour de la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants en attendant dernière étape
aujourd'hui de la levée des contraintes
sanitaires fin des restrictions de
georges pour les restaurants magasins et
commerces partout dans l'hexagone sauf
dans les landes
grégoire dos et peu à peu les
contraintes sanitaires s'efface dans
l'hexagone conformément aux annonces du
gouvernement dans son plan de
déconfinement en plusieurs phases ce
mercredi 30 juin marque la fin de
nombreuses restrictions
fini les jauges dans les restaurants
bars haut lieu culturel
exception faite des salles de concerts
et des festivals qui pourront se remplir
jusqu'à 75% de leurs capacités en
intérieur exception territoriale
également avec le département des landes
dans lequel le variante delta s'est
implantée depuis plusieurs semaines dans
les landes où j'ai évoqué la semaine
dernière une situation d' alerte
l'épidémie semble avoir été contenus à
ce stade il est trop tôt pour le dire
mais il ya une relative stabilisation
même si elle reste à la hausse c'est
notamment grâce à une campagne de
dépistage massif de traçage et de
vaccination renforcée nous avons
augmenté de 5 portes de 50% la location
des doses de vaccin néanmoins dans ce
département la situation reste trop
instable trop fragile et nous nous
voulons prendre absolument aucun risque
de voir l'épidémie et redémarrer le
gouvernement qui appelle toutefois à
maintenir les gestes barrières et la
vigilance
la menace du variant delta plus
contagieux par rapport à la souche
initial et aux variants britannique est
au coeur de toutes les inquiétudes
je crois qu'on aura une quatrième vague
mais qu'elle va être beaucoup plus
nuancée que les trois premières car il y
à un niveau de vaccination qui n'est pas
du tout le même
le vaccin est efficace quand on a eu
deux injections
d'où le message il faut se faire
vacciner et avoir eu ces deux injections
pour la rentrée l'exécutif qui compte
donc plus que jamais sur la vaccination
pour limiter les formes graves de covile
19 problème après avoir tourné à plein
régime
la campagne vaccinale observe un net
ralentissement
ces dernières semaines et dans les
landes le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand accusé une soignante non
vaccinés d'être à l'origine de la
contamination dans un ait pas de
pontonx-sur-l'adour qui a causé deux
morts la cgt y voit un coup de pression
sur les personnels qui n'ont pas encore
reçu l'injection
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec yannick jacobson secrétaire général
de la cgt santé et action sociale dans
les landes bonsoir yannick jacobson
merci d'être avec nous pour vous aussi
beaucoup de pression il appropriée de la
part du ministre verrons oui c'est des
propos inappropriés inappropriée et qui
stigmatisent vraiment des personnels
soignants
c'est même des propos quasiment est
discriminatoire envers une profession
qui étaient acclamés il ya un an et
maintenant pour une politique vaccinale
qui est désarmant insultes on voudrait
faire passer exactement la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants en se
servant de ce qui se passe à l'ehpad de
pontonx donc oui c'est vraiment
discriminatoire est il vraiment une
action politique pour bien qu'on
comprenne votre point de vue est le
point de vue de votre syndicat ce que
vous déplorez là ce n'est pas forcément
le débat sur la vaccination obligatoire
d'aidé soignant mais c'est cette méthode
peut-être pour y arriver
selon vous oui c'est la méthode on
incrimine des soignants ont déjà à s'en
prendre
la directrice de l'établissement est
aussi le directeur de la rs de la
nouvelle aquitaine est beaucoup plus
prudent sur
le porteur du virus qui a emmené comment
dans l'établissement le virus donc oui
j'ai la mienne la méthode n'est pas
appropriée et le débat aussi
l'obligation de vacciner et pourquoi
stigmatiser les soignants dans ce cas là
tout le monde devrait être vaccinée
pourquoi pas vacciner les enseignants
les chauffeurs de bus faut rappeler que
la vaccination ne protège pas comment
d'attraper le virus c'est seulement sur
des formes graves et on peut être
porteur donc n'importe qui peut être
porteur et il faut quand même savoir que
dans cet établissement il ya déjà eu un
résident qui a été contaminé en début du
mois
donc voilà imposer la vaccination au
gouvernement faut pas oublier quand même
que ce même gouvernement il ya quelques
mois imposée aux agents positif 1
symptomatique d'aller travailler donc
deux poids deux mesures et se servir
politiquement comment du personnel
soignant pour faire avaler la vaccine
obligatoire qui après les soignons sera
obligatoire à tout le monde
la cgt les pas contre les vaccins mais
bien sûr et compte et pour une liberté
individuelle des travailleurs et
travailleuses à se faire vacciner de
leurs progrès vous vous dites
effectivement la vaccination dans ce cas
tout le monde devrait se faire vacciner
mais vous savez aussi bien que moi que
la profession soignants c'est très
particulier ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
ce sont tout simplement les les nombreux
médecins l'académie de médecine acquis
qui parlait même d'une faute morale on a
entendu et lu plein de médecins qui
pensaient cela c'est vrai que c'est
délicat quand on soigne des personnes
très fragile et âgée de prendre le
risque de leur transmettre
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre
notamment aux familles qui sont
inquiètes
alors ce qu'on peut répondre c'est que
les soignants et les personnels
soignants sont des efforts surhumains
pour protéger la population travaillent
dans des conditions vraiment délétère
peut-être que avoir plus de personnel
soignant
ça permettrait bien sûr d'appliquer les
protocoles plus à la lettre d'être moins
fatigués tête - de faire d'erreur et
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on
peut comment être porteur sans le savoir
déjà d'une vacciner ou non n'importe qui
nourrit pas n'oubliez pas que on peut
aller en visite à nos patients à des
patients à des résidents le virus peut
être transporté par n'importe quelle
personne donc et stigmatiser encore une
fois la profession de sonia qui a aussi
également perdu un lourd tribut dans
dans cette épidémie les peuples était la
chose la meilleure des choses à faire
soignante veulent pas se faire vacciner
sont par exemple suspendu dans un état
comme le texas aux états unis sont
écartés en italie vous trouvez ça
choquant oui c'est choquant n'oublie pas
qu'en france on a déjà une pénurie de
personnel soignant le personnel qui te
la vie ratoire un bien sûr à cause des
conditions de travail délétères qui sont
effectués de dd payent des salaires
minimums on a déjà du mal à trouver des
personnels soignants donc bay ou
obligeant le personnel se faire sony est
peut-être ça fera encore faire partir
plus de professionnels donc jean castex
qui entament ces consultations il faut
me d'ici la fin de l'été la vaccination
soit quasi complète sinon effectivement
il faudra prendre nos responsabilités il
parle notamment de la vaccination des
soignants susceptibles d'être
obligatoire ces consultations et vous
inquiète clairement aujourd'hui elle est
inquiète
win on sait très bien que le
gouvernement un jour dit blanc un jour
dire aux donc depuis début de l'épidémie
même les preuves des professionnels de
santé savent plus sur quel pied danser
les protocoles les normes changent tous
les jours donc on peut plutôt remercier
le personnel de santé
appliqué à la lettre ce qui est dit par
le gouvernement et donc à éviter que
condemi se propage dans l'établissement
est-ce que les protocoles aussi appliqué
b sont efficaces voilà on ne sait pas
encore donc et puis vous dira tout aussi
tous ses médecins et ses professeurs sur
tous les plateaux télé mais qui viennent
peut-être un peu dans les services revue
qui retournent dans les services ou
alors comment ça se passe et on est
obligé d'y obligé la vaccination mais
voilà c'est un une entrave à la liberté
de choisir nous mêmes
merci a été mis k comme ça d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rtl france
le port du voile dans les bureaux de
vote le débat déchaîné les passions hier
soir dans l'hémicycle pendant près de
deux heures les députés ont bataillé
autour d'un bref amendement finalement
rejetée et maintenant du modem et qui
aurait est interdit tout signe
ostentatoire d'appartenance religieuse
pour le personnel des bureaux de vote
si l'obligation neutralité religieuse ne
concerne que les présidents et
présidentes de bureau le sujet reste
malgré tout très clivant alors les
assesseurs voilée pour vos comptes
menace pour la laïcité ou victoire de
l'intégration c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir prêt pour en
débattre nous sommes avec david guiraud
porte parole jeunesse la france
insoumise julien houde ou le conseiller
régional rn1 bourgogne franche comté
membre du bureau national du rnd bonsoir
tous les deux messieurs merci d'être
avec nous donc c'est une polémique a un
qui a ronflé sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui a fait rage dans toute la nuit à
l'assemblée nationale même si
l'amendement était rejeté un finalement
le précise le débat on voit reste
extrêmement vif et et surtout très
clivant tout est parti à d'ailleurs de
cette photo publiée par jordan bardella
en guyane le dimanche 20 juin lors du
premier tour des régionales voilà cette
photo à voter a dit sobrement un jordan
bardella julien odoul clairement ça nous
a choqués cette photo ce qui porte à
cette question est ce qu'un assesseur
peut arborer un signe ostensible de
religion selon vous oui cette photo est
choquant dans un bureau de vote
la neutralité devrait être la règle la
neutralité devrait être la norme
la neutralité politique et la neutralité
religieuse
cette assesseurs donc qui portent ce
voile islamique qui n'est pas un
vêtement anodin qui évidemment un signe
un emblème politico religieux
contrevient au principe de neutralité et
ce qui est choquant c'est que tous les
six mois
nous avons ce débat sur le voile tous
les six mois
nous avons des provocations les
provocations communautariste islamistes
et tous les 6 mois vous avez le goût
en nommant qui est la tête dans le sable
vous avez des débats qui ne sont pas
tranchés parce que clairement il faut
qu'en france on est ce débat en france
le voile n'est pas souhaitable
le voile n'a rien à faire en france le
voile n'est pas la culture française
n'est pas notre identité nationale
le voile n'est pas nos principes
républicains dont clairement il faut
trancher cela que ce soit pour
évidemment les assesseurs ce soit d'un
qu'en france on est encore ce débat là
pour du personnel qui effectue une
mission de service public et je dirais
la mission de service public la plus
essentielle puisque c'est la mission de
service public qui favorise qui organise
la démocratie la démocratie doit être
dans ce cadre-là extrêmement rigoureuse
extrêmement neutre on ne pourrait pas
accepter que dans un bureau de vote vous
ayez des logos des pin's des t-shirts de
partis politiques
évidemment que ça contrevient au
principe de neutralité vous ne pouvez
pas accepter que des voiles islamiques
soient exhibé dans un bureau de vote
pareil pour les sorties scolaires les
accompagnatrices colère qui sont dans un
cadre de l'éducation nationale dans la
prolongation de l'éducation nationale
qui effectue une mission de service
public ne devrait pas pouvoir exhiber
2,6 politico religieux ostentatoires il
faut qu'une bonne fois pour toutes nos
gouvernants les grandes personnes qui
nous gouvernent tranche ce débat et
arrête de reculer parce qu'à chaque fois
que nous avons ce genre de provocation
c'est la république qui recule ce sont
nos principes qui reculent ça sert à
rien de parler de séparatisme matin midi
et soir
si on n'est pas capable de trancher ce
débat est tout simplement de cantonner
la religion de cantonner l'entrisme de
continuer le productif en dehors des
affaires de la république en dehors des
bureaux de vote
en dehors des sorties scolaires en
dehors aussi de l'espace public car
encore une fois le voile n'est pas un
vêtement anodin c'est un emblème
politique qui participe du développement
du communautarisme islamique et qui a
entretenu comme tel et on le voit aussi
d'ailleurs à la piscine on le voit sur
nos plages avec ce débat incessant sur
le burkina qui n'est rien qui n'est en
rien un vêtement
religieux d'ailleurs puisque puisque
puisque c'est on le sait très bien à
bordeaux n'est bien évidemment génère
donc terminé le dur le burqini n'est pas
un vêtement religieux le but le but he
qui est juste un emblème politique qui
sert de provocation permanente pour
développer le communautarisme
il faut que ce débat soit tranché une
bonne fois pour toutes david hierro
plusieurs idées qu'on va évidemment dont
on va débattre ici le principe de
neutralité mais aussi c'est vrai cette
incapacité à trancher
manifestement en france sur ce type de
dossier on sent une fébrilité
vous aussi vous pensez qu'il faut très
clairement tranché et dans quel sens moi
je crois surtout que c'est l'été et que
comme chaque été faut payer des gens en
compet déperdition qui connaissent rien
aux lois de notre pays rien à l'identité
républicaine de notre pays
comme julien odoul qui sortent pour
cracher sur les musulmans pour exister
politiquement je viens au double c'est
un grand champion
on le connaît il l'a déjà fait au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté qu'il espérait gagner d'ailleurs
il s'est fait piétiner par le parti
socialiste
là il continue à cracher pour exister
politiquement mais franchement cette
dame elle s'élevait un dimanche
elle s'élevait à 1 dimanche à une
élection il ya que 30% des français qui
sont allés voter pour tenir un bureau de
vote on n'arrête pas de nous parler
d'intégrer les musulmans à la république
et quand vous avez une femme qui va
justement aider à la bonne tenue des
élections
on lui dit qu'il faut qu'elle parte
enfin je veux dire il ya un moment faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
monsieur odoul nous sort des arguments
extrêmement fallacieux il nous dit les
bureaux de vote il doit y avoir une
neutralité politique et religieuse mais
vous savez pas le droit dans le droit
français la neutralité politique allait
garantir la neutralité religieuse par
contre pour les assesseurs
elle est ouverte pourquoi parce que les
assesseurs et représente pas l'état
monsieur ou double y représentent les
candidats et les candidats ils n'ont pas
à être neutres religieusement vous en
faites ce que vous voulez au sein de
votre organisation politique mais ils
n'ont pas à être neutres religieusement
sinon ça veut dire que vous êtes pour la
dissolution du parti chrétien démocrate
qui n'est pas neutre religieusement
sinon avec des gens comme vous qui
piétinait l'histoire et l'identité de
notre pays n'y aurait pas eu d' abbey
pierre qui est élu député il y aurait
pas eu de chanoine félix kir qui a été
député pendant 22 ans qui a été maire de
dijon de 1945 c'était un résistant
jusqu'à sa mort il y aurait pas eu ça
nous voilà donc en fait on est en face
de gens qui arrivent comme ça
qui vous donnent des grandes leçons de
république mais qui n'ont pas compris
que la laïcité c'est fait pour apaiser
la france c'est pas fait pour faire des
guerres de religion
et quand j'entends dire que soit disant
il faudrait que les religions ne se mêle
pas des affaires de la france mais enfin
monsieur 12 mai vous êtes qui pour pour
dire ça les religions il ya une loi de
séparation des églises et de l'état qui
est clair il n'y a pas besoin de
légiférer
il n'y a pas besoin de passer deux
heures à l'assemblée pour se demander si
une assesseurs doit porter le voile ou
pas pour savoir que la loi de 1905 elle
existe mais pour ça c'est vrai hein faut
connaître le droit
alors bon il faut travailler ces sujets
on va on apprend qu'à tout moment
messieurs à la racine à l'assemblée
nationale avec la position de renault
1000 yens député modem dans les yvelines
qui a tenté
donc effectivement de convaincre de
voter cet amendement écoutez le le fait
d'aller voter c'est quelque chose que
l'on doit sacraliser les lecteurs qui va
voter effectivement ne sait pas qui sont
les assesseurs qui est le président du
bureau et je pense que ce lieu-là doit
être totalement neutre et les assesseurs
doivent être d'une neutralité totale
qu'elle soit politique ou religieuse
comme ça il n'y aura aucune influence
sur le vote
vous êtes donc une fois n'est pas
coutume je viens au bol totalement
d'accord avec le modem
totalement d'accord avec les propos de
bruno myle yens évidemment et c'est vrai
que bon les arguments du représentant de
la france islamistes me ne m'étonne pas
sont toujours les mêmes c'est à dire on
n'a pas ces deux accompagnatrices
scolaire donc il faut évidemment ouvrir
les bras à celles qui sont voilées on
n'a pas ces d'assesseurs en france donc
on ne peut pas rejeter celles qui sont
voilées et qui contreviennent excusez
moi monsieur guiraud nonobstant le droit
qui contreviennent aux principes de
neutralité puisque vous oublié quelque
chose
la fameuse loi 1905 dont vous parlez
matin midi et soir
vous avez oublié que dans les débats
elles demandaient notamment que les
religions choix discrète discrète dans
l'espace public vous comprenez discrète
et le voile contrevient totalement
bafoués au principe de discrétion
bambins tout ce principe de discrétion
parce que je sais bien que c'est votre
nouvelle clientèle électorale qui de
plus en plus faibles il faut bien le
dire
d'ici là
je les ai été retenu en tenue d' abbey à
l'assemblée nationale s'est dit ce
monsieur monsieur guiraud monsieur
giraud le chat le voile hérité en
soutane c'est discret je sais que pour
vous le voile finalement n'est qu un
serre tête ou qu un bandana
mais la réalité les dramatiques
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est que le jeu
le voile islamique
aujourd'hui est tout sauf un vêtement et
c'est tout sauf la liberté de le porter
le voile islamique est entretenu et
instrumentalisé comme un emblème du
communautarisme et de l'islamisme à tant
d'injustice et mourir et je vais juste
je suis terminé juste amener et que une
personne qui se dévoue
comme vous l'avez des trajets pour aller
dans un bureau de vote pour effectuer
cette mission essentielle d'organiser un
scrutin est d'aider à sa bonne
organisation que cette personne vienne
avec un voile islamique mais pourquoi le
temps le temps de cette journée ne
peut-elle pas rester neutre neutre voilà
pour que le lait la journée se déroule
sereinement compte tenu de l'importance
de la journée
non répond dans quelques instants julien
au bout mais on va faire un petit détour
par eric ciotti qui en substance dit
exprime cette idée que vient de de dire
donc julien ont dû l'écouter
si on débat c'est parce qu'il ya eu des
français assassiné c'est parce qu'il ya
eu un professeur décapité et parce qu'il
y a un problème qu'il convient de
combattre avec énergie et avec
détermination
vous ne voulez rien changé ce texte est
un filet d'eau tiède et david guiraud
eric ciotti au moins d'accord avec nous
ou pas qui a le mérite d'exprimer en
tout cas ce qui peut choquer une
certaine partie des français
un symbole politique est ce que vous
comprenez que ça puisse heurter ses
sensibilités laon tout cas mais j'adore
les gens comme monsieur ciotti ou
monsieur odoul qui nous explique que le
voile c'est pas un abîme et c'est quoi
alors si c'est pas un habit pardon c'est
une chaussure c'est quoi c'est un cintre
c'est un lampadaire qui êtes vous pour
définir ce qu'est un habit pardon mais
il ya un moment ça devient ridicule
cette discussion ridicule je vous assure
un parce que ça devient complètement
absurde on débat de
deux choses dont on ne sait même plus de
quoi on parle monsieur odoul être en
train de nous dire en gros le voile
islamique nécessite quoi une législation
spécifique c'est ça il faut l'interdire
spécifiquement je vais juste vous
rappeler au cas où vous n'êtes pas au
courant parce qu'en plus il opine du
chef
c'est bien bas il connaît pas l'article
premier de la constitution du 4 octobre
1958 à l'article 1er c'est à dire pas le
sait même pas le cinquième le 6ème temps
le premier le plus important je vais
vous lire comme ça vous comprendrez la
france est une république indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale
et je vous lis je cite elle assure
l'égalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens sans distinction d'origine de
race ou de religion
donc vous pouvez pas légiférer sur une
religion en particulier c'est
anticonstitutionnel
il faut connaître l'histoire de son pays
il faut connaître la constitution de son
pays et les lois de son pays c'est très
important quand on aspire à gouverner le
pays monsieur au dessus monsieur giraud
nous ne faisons aucune distinction entre
les religions et entre les croyants
parce que vous voyez vous parlez de
musulmans moi je parle de français de
confession musulmane parce que moi ils
doivent d'abord être français est
français c'est quoi c'est déjà se plier
aux lois de la république au 10 mai est
aussi est aussi à la culture française
aux moeurs françaises à l'identité
nationale parce que le français mais
monsieur monsieur n'est pas moi la
culture veut c'est monsieur s'est passé
vous n'êtes pas l'attitude dé vos
bêtises quand vous par kamba v6 et avec
les pires imams radicaux monsieur guy
roux quand vous manifestez main dans la
main avec le ccf
quand vous manifester avec un boa nahd
en novembre 2019 a donc on a fait une
association une parole ce qu'on peut pas
élire d'accord à 2 à la suite d'un
attentat terroriste choses autrement et
et imaginer tout simplement que ça donne
et moi messieurs ce qu on vous entend
pas seul on parlait tous les deux en
même temps est-ce qu'on ne peut pas voir
justement cet acte comme un être plutôt
apaisant
et d'intégration voilà cette femme qui
bénévoles au service de l'état est ce
que cette pensée peut vous effleurez
évidemment et surtout et surtout ça
nécessite pas qu'on y passer des
castings
j'ai peut-être dit vigneault cela des
rues but qui parle de vue qu'il est très
bon
non mais je dis je je dis ça parce que
je dis ça parce que les arguments qui
sont énoncées par monsieur doute sur
l'identité française où la culture
française mais pardon mais ce n'est pas
le rassemblement national qui peut
définir ce qu'est la culture française
ce que j'essaie de vous dire que la vie
justement cet organisateur
en six ans le monsieur odoul rompe avec
le principe de laïcité
ils veulent une laïcité et d'ailleurs il
ya eu des débats à l'époque c'est vrai
il y avait des débats l'époque de la loi
de laïcité
vous aviez des gens comme aristide
briand qui vous disaient écouter on a
déjà bien mis l'église catholique à bas
on a fait la séparation des églises et
de l'état
on va peut-être pas interdire la soutane
dans la rue d'accord c'était ce débat là
avant et maintenant c'est la conception
qu'il vous en aviez d'autres des
républicains pour ses coups bas les
ordonnances cardiff où les signes
religieux
effectivement un signe d'intégration
force va pas
julien odoul cette femme après tout est
bénévole au service de l'état d'ailleurs
votre collègue bardella pas vraiment
l'air effrayé
non mais c'est l'échec total de
l'intégration l'échec total de
l'assimilation car si cette femme était
assimilé aux lois de la république à
notre culture à notre identité nationale
jamais elle ne mettrait cet emblème
politico religieux pour venir effectuer
cette mission de service public
c'est un échec total et le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez un
gouvernement qui recule en permanence
vous avez d'un côté monsieur blanc caire
qui a deux ans nous disait que le voile
n'était pas souhaitable dans la société
française et la sueur quand même un
symbole extrêmement fort nous sommes
dans un bureau de vote
nous ne sommes pas dans une boulangerie
nous sommes dans un bureau de vote c'est
à dire que c'est là où s'exerce la
démocratie dans notre pays
sixième puissance démocratique du monde
donc clairement est ce qu'à un moment
donné on peut avoir un gouvernement qui
ne tremble pas qu'ils réaffirment nos
principes et qui nous disent tout
simplement le voile comme tous les
signes religieux ostentatoires ne sont
pas souhaitables dans ce cadre là le
voile comme emblème politico religieux
doit être combattu car encore une fois
derrière il ya une idéologie mortifère
en honnête compris vos deux fois levé
merci david hay et remercié à julian
ville d'avoir été avec ton nommé david
guiraud monaco on voit là on vous a
laissé débattra à temps égal je pense
merci à tous les deux m'ont rapidement
mais vous allez continuer david guiraud
je vous connais la loi ne dit pas ce qui
est souhaitable et les moniales par ce
qui est autorisé ou bien interdits
si vous commencez à dire que la loi
disent qu'ils se tapent ce que vous
connaissez pas ce que c'est qu'une loi
dans un pays merci à tous les deux voilà
vous avez une mot de la fin merci david
guiraud et julien au double dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'attaqué au couteau qui a secoué la
ville allemande de nouveau en bavière
perpétré vendredi dernier trois femmes
ont trouvé la mort l'an quête de police
se poursuit puis direction ensuite le
liban où les crises se succèdent le prix
des carburants ont augmenté de plus de
30% après une levée partielle
subventions
[Musique]
oh
vous
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis que le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers étaient compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai
sujet c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français les poignées
britannique est ce qui m'inquiète dans
le bric site c'est par le break 6 et la
bureaucratie du brics
comment ça va se passer par exemple pour
l'été qui arrive la côte d'azur verra
peu ou pas d'anglais je suspecte
effectivement le gouvernement
britannique d'essayer de convaincre les
britanniques que de rester en grande
bretagne pour faciliter la relance de
l'économie britannique par rapport à la
crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
je
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental on est tous
conscients que le football ligny tout ce
qui est au niveau social surtout au
niveau aux cultures et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en entend
tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et non surtout au niveau du beau
football et ça c'est touchant
[Musique]
assiste-t-on à une soviétisation de
l'économie c'est simplement une place de
plus en plus prépondérante de l'état
aujourd'hui avec les prêts garantis par
l'état et que fait l'état se paye les
entreprises l'état pourrait devenir un
partenaire un actionnaire d'outré un
très grand nombre d'entreprises
françaises
on est un peu dans une logique
d'économie de guerre où l état a suppléé
on va dire à la défaillance du privé on
est dans quelque chose qui ressemble à
une soviétisation il est vrai que le
gouvernement n'avait aujourd'hui pas
d'autre moyen que de faire le point
qu'il en coûte
l'état aujourd'hui aide tout et
n'importe quoi et c'est bien le problème
qui va soutenir va va subir ça c'est
nous dans nos impôts
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez les
européens qui habite au royaume uni y
avait jusqu'à ce soir pour faire une
demande de statut de résident s'il
souhaitait rester dans le pays
ce statut garantit la continuité de
leurs droits en matière de travail ou de
santé londres a exclu un report de
l'échéance mais pourrait faire preuve de
souplesse les précisions de mediagrif il
le reste jusqu'à ce soir minuit pour
déposer leurs demandes de permis de
résidence
les ressortissants européens qui vivent
au royaume uni ce perdront leur droit de
séjour s'ils ne font pas le nécessaire
avant l'heure fatidique
ils n'auront plus le droit de travailler
dans le territoire ni d'y louer un
logement ou de bénéficier du système de
santé dans la capitale britannique
il y a notamment des associations qui
proposent leur aide aux candidats de
dernière minute pour compléter et
remplir leur dossier
alors que le temps presse certains
peinent à réunir les documents
nécessaires
cela fait 26 ans que je suis ici je
pense que cela devrait signifier quelque
chose non je n'ai pas besoin de
présenter un dossier pour le prouver
dans mon coeur je suis britannique
c'est juste que sur le papier je suis
française mais cela fait 26 ans que je
suis ici
plus de la moitié de ma vie donc non je
n'ai pas du tout aimé ça
la date butoir du 1er juillet ne sera
pas repoussé d'après les autorités
britanniques alors que le gouvernement
français vient d'accorder un délai
supplémentaire de trois mois aux
britanniques installés dans l'hexagone
les demandes de permis de séjour au
royaume uni se multiplient ces derniers
jours
au total 5,6 millions de dossiers ont
été déposés et 350 mille d'entre eux
n'ont pas reçu de réponse 97% d'entre
elles ont été acceptées et seulement 1%
refusé dans cette course contre la
montre les médias britanniques remarque
une saturation dans la liste d'attentes
dû à un nombre de demande trop
importante ces dernières
or il y a beaucoup de dossiers complexes
que l'on essaie de faire passer et qui
sont entravés par le fait que les gens
ne parviennent pas à obtenir de l'aide
les organisations mises en place pour
aider les gens sont également déborder
le système est à un point de rupture
il y aura beaucoup de personnes
vulnérables dans des situations
complexes qui ne trouveront pas qui
contacter parce qu'elles n'auront pas vu
les alertes de dernière minute sur les
réseaux sociaux
quant aux ressortissants de l'ue eux qui
n'auront pas réussi à déposer leurs
demandes dans les délais le gouvernement
de sa majesté tient à les rassurer
le ministre britannique de l'immigration
assure que ces personnes ne verrait pas
leurs droits sociaux disparaître du jour
au lendemain
nous accepterons les enregistrements
tardif lorsqu ils seront accompagnés de
motifs raisonnables
notre première réaction sera de leur
donnait 28 jours supplémentaires pour
faire une demande tardive
plutôt que de procéder à des mesures
d'exécution et tout au long
nous serons guidés par une approche
flexible et pragmatique
une disposition qui pourrait concerner
des dizaines de milliers d'européens et
toujours à propos du break site
l'autorisation d'accès aux eaux
britanniques pour les pêcheurs normands
et bretons devraient prendre fin
aujourd'hui mais le gouvernement de
jersey décidé en début de semaine
d'octroyer un délai de trois mois
supplémentaires
les détails avec valentin carpentier une
véritable bouffée d'air frais après des
mois d'attentes
l'union européenne a obtenu l'accord du
gouvernement de jazz et sur l'extension
des licences de ces bateaux une
prolongation jusqu'au 31 septembre
prochain alors que la pêche dans les
îles anglo-normandes aurait dû s'arrêter
dès ce mercredi
une aubaine pour les pêcheurs français
principaux concernés le gouvernement
dodgers et s'est lui aussi félicité de
ce report dans un communiqué jersey se
félicite du dialogue engagé sur les
plans techniques et politiques avec le
royaume unis l'union européenne et la
france en vue d'une résolution des
enjeux complexes et sensibles relatifs à
la pêche
ce report a été annoncé après des mois
de négociations tendues entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni
et ce malgré l'accord trouvé entre les
deux parties sur les relations post
break site un texte en vigueur depuis le
1er janvier dernier
depuis plusieurs semaines des bateaux de
pêche normands et bretons s'étaient
rassemblés dans le port de jazz et en
signe de mécontentement
le gouvernement français avait
officiellement demandé ce report
il y à une loi prise par jersey qui
limitent ou qui détermine des
restrictions supplémentaires technique
inadmissible on l'a dit immédiatement
alors où on en est aujourd'hui et vient
jersey vient de nous proposer de
reporter c'est restrictions techniques à
fin juillet de manière à ce que prennent
les discussions dans les heures qui
viennent je répondrai par écrit la
france répondra par écrit si la ministre
de la mer s'est déclarée ravie de la
décision de jazz et le temps est
désormais à la négociation
union européenne et royaume uni ont
trois mois pour trouver un nouvel accord
et proposer une solution aux centaines
de pêcheurs concernés
on en vient à l'attaqué au couteau qui a
secoué la ville allemande de würzburg en
bavière perpétré vendredi dernier trois
femmes ont trouvé la mort l enquête de
police se poursuit entre et le point
avec peter oliver correspondant rtl
berne ce pays le parquet de munich qui
enquête sur l'attaqué au couteau de
vendredi dernier dans la ville de
würzburg en bavière au sud de
l'allemagne a rendu publiques deux
nouveaux éléments
trois personnes ont été tuées et sept
autres blessées
le suspect principal a été blessé à la
jambe par le tir d'un officier de police
l'homme de 24 ans est en détention et
est interrogé en ce moment même sur les
événements de vendredi
d'après les dernières informations du
cabinet du procureur la thèse de
l'extrémisme islamiste n'est pas exclue
il se fonde sur les cris de allah akbar
dieu est grand en arabe poussé par le
suspect pendant l' attaque et à ses
références lors de son hospitalisation à
ces actions comme étant son dû
souligne cependant que bien qu'ils
exploreront la piste de l'extrémisme
islamiste
ils n'ont pas trouvé de propagande
islamiste sur le suspect lui-même ni
dans son appartement et n'ont pas établi
de lien entre des extrémistes notoire et
le suspect l'enquêté se concentre tout
particulièrement sur deux téléphones
portables avec d'autres effets
personnels découvert au domicile du
suspect principal
ils ont été passés au peigne fin et leur
contenu analysées par des experts de
l'extrémisme afin de permettre aux
autorités d'aller au fond de l'enquète
le suspect est également soumis à une
évaluation psychologique afin de
déterminer s'il est apte à subir un
procès pour les actions dont ils d'être
accusé trois meurtres et cette tentative
de meurtre lors de l' attaque du
vendredi après-midi avec béria les
autorités affirme étudier plus d'une
centaine de pistes concernant le motif
de cette attaque et tiennent à souligner
que bien qu'ils explorent la possibilité
d'une attaque extrémistes l'enquêté
tankan line best games continue
au liban les crises se succèdent
inexorablement les prix des carburants
ont augmenté de plus de 30% après une
levée partielle des subventions et des
semaines de pénurie à la crise
économique s'ajoute la crise politique
le pays du cèdre n'a toujours pas de
gouvernement
françois xavier lambert
les mêmes scènes se répètent depuis
plusieurs semaines partout au liban
des files interminables de voitures
attendent de pouvoir faire le plein dans
les stations service alors que les
pénuries de carburant paralyse le pays
les libanais font désormais face à une
augmentation des prix à la pompe
en cause une baisse importante des
subventions accordées aux importateurs
de carburants par la banque centrale
dz devenu impossible en raison de
l'épuisement des réserves de dollars de
l'institution financière
conséquence le prix du bidon de sans
plomb 95 est passé de 31 à 41 dollars et
cette hausse devrait inévitablement se
répercutait sur d'autres secteurs tout
en alimentant l'inflation en dollar
s'échange désormais contre plus de 17000
livres libanaises pour les habitants la
situation est de plus en plus difficile
à supporter assez de tromperie assez
d'humiliation a cédé aux pressions
honte à vous de vous être retournée
contre le peuple honte à vous ils
veulent augmenter le prix chaque jour
nous sommes humiliés dans les stations
service depuis 7 heures du matin je me
tiens ici il n'y a pas de crise c'est ce
que les politiciens veulent faire au
peuple
il humilie les gens ont un pays comme
celui-là on à ces politiciens
cette hausse des prix des carburants est
une mauvaise nouvelle de plus dans un
pays qui enchaîne les crises depuis près
de deux ans malgré une économie dévastée
la crise sanitaire
la classe politique ne parvient toujours
pas à former un nouveau gouvernement
depuis la démission du précédent premier
ministre en août dernier une démission
qui survenaient suite à l'explosion du
port de beyrouth qui a fait plus de 200
morts
face à l'urgence de la situation les
ministres des affaires étrangères
américain français saoudiens appelle les
dirigeants libanais à surmonter leurs
différends pour résoudre la crise
discussions importantes avec mes
homologues saoudiens et français
concernant la nécessité pour les
dirigeants politiques libanais de faire
preuve d'un réel leadership en mettant
en oeuvre des réformes attendues depuis
longtemps pour stabiliser l'économie et
apporter au peuple libanais un
soulagement dont il a tant besoin
selon la banque mondiale le liban est
englué dans une des pires crises
économiques
monde depuis 1850 d'après l'onu plus de
la moitié de la population vit déjà sous
le seuil de pauvreté et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis beyrouth
avec mounir douma ni membre du parti
libanais citoyens et citoyennes dans un
état c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soit bonsoir on y re doux
mais me merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on vient de voir un les
prix des carburants qui augmente de 30%
en cause de la suppression partielle les
subventions qui à terme devrait
totalement disparaître
on se demande comment la population
libanaise va pouvoir faire face alors
que le liban est en plein chaos déjà
c'est une c'est une question en effet
très compliqué nous faisons face
je pense que le reportage à et c'est
assez a été assez fidèle à ce qui se
passe ici nous faisons face a pris
véritablement un régime criminel qui
tout en vivant les ces derniers ces
derniers mois probablement vu la
pression auxquels il fait face s'acharne
à faire porter aux libanais le prix de
de leur mauvaise gestion durant toutes
ces années donc nous sommes dans une
phase à une situation où il y à des
pertes à partager dans ce pays un régime
confessionnel ne peut pas partager des
pertes tout ce qu'ils peuvent faire
c'est partager le résultat de leurs deux
des 2 de skins pis à travers le système
donc ils sont dans l'incapacité de gérer
les pertes façon autre que comptable
comme ils le font aujourd'hui
donc ils font payer le prix aux gens
s'en sont sans aucune considération pain
pour le propos pour la catastrophe qui
nous font vivre au quotidien
clairement est ce qu'il y aurait une
autre solution et si oui laquelle
écoutez oui il y à une solution je fais
partie d'un parti politique qui militent
pour cette solution depuis 2016 puisque
nous avons été fondés spécifiquement
parce que nous savions que le système
arrivé à sa fin de route
la solution au liban aujourd'hui et
l'établissement et l'établissement d'un
état laïc qui serait confiant dans sa
légitimité qui serait capable lui même
de gérer les pertes de façon équitable
entre les libanais encore une fois le
système confessionnel pas parce que il
ne sait pas ou parce qu'il ne veut pas
mais parce qu'il ne peut pas fonctionner
lmnp aujourd'hui traités avec une
situation pareille
et effectivement après avoir fait subir
15 ans de guerre aux libanais les chefs
de guerre confessionnelle continuent
leur leur traitement de criminels de la
situation aujourd'hui quinze ans après
la fin plutôt trente ans après la fin de
la guerre enfin n'est pas la fin de la
guerre mais plutôt la fin des hostilités
parce que la guerre elle même n'est pas
terminé puisque nous vivons une
situation qui est qui est ok aussi
caraquet et qui est aussi catastrophique
donc aujourd'hui il y a des gens au
liban qu dont nous faisons partie qui
sont en train de militer pour
l'établissement d'un état véritable dans
ce pays seuls capables de gérer une
crise telle que nous la vivons parce que
sinon vous avez mentionné les
interventions une intervention assez
dirait limite comics 2
de l'ambassadeur américain qui ont bien
du mystère étrangères américain qui
c'est qui s'est réuni avec ses
homologues séoudiens et français et qui
appelle à des réformes
la quantité de crise nous aujourd'hui au
liban ne peut être résolue par des
réformes c'est un mot qui est qui et qui
est quasiment qu'il ya une dimension de
d'insultés aux gens ils nous avons un
véritablement besoin d'un changement de
système complet et encore une fois il y
a des gens qui s'y activent et qui
essaye de faire en sorte que cette crise
ne sont pas une fatalité mais une
opportunité pour se diriger vers quelque
chose qui puisse redonner de l'espoir
aux libanais et cette chose là n'oublie
pas les chefs de guerre confessionnelle
allié des états-unis de la france
d'ailleurs le magazine américain foreign
policy a son idée sur la question il a
consacré quelques colonnes cette crise
libanaise est dit en substance à
l'impasse libanaise est en partie la
faute d' emmanuel macron est ce que vous
partagez cet avis expliquant il faut
lire évidemment cet article complet mais
en gros que la france agit td des
sanctions qui n'ont jamais eu lieu
c'était un échec finalement de
l'initiative française
écoutez nous en tant que mouvement nous
avons suivi de très près l'évolution de
la position française qui a oscillé
entre les premiers jours qui ont suivi
l'explosion du port de beyrouth du 4
du 4 août cette position s'est
développée c'était au début
au début c'était un peu vague puis c'est
devenu un gouvernement de mission puis
ensuite ils se sont pliés au
gouvernement d'union nationale comme
ceux qui ont géré le pays durant les 15
dernières années et qui ont montré leur
incapacité à le faire pour arriver à une
dernière déclaration de jean yves le
drian le ministre des affaires
étrangères qui avait déclaré il y a dix
il y a deux mois à peu près si je ne
m'abuse qu' il était temps d'avoir un
gouvernement de transition qui puisse
prendre les pays et une direction
différente me semble que ce n'était que
des déclarations à ce moment là la
france aujourd'hui se montre encore une
fois son incapacité à dépasser son
attachement à un système qu'elle a
finalement contribué à instaurer
il y a longtemps de cela et encore une
fois elle est face à l'impasse et donc
ce n'est pas seulement le rôle de la
france mais de tous les pays qui ont un
intérêt dans la région je parle de la
france des états unis de la russie de
l'iran
tous ces pays là n'ont pas intérêt à ce
que le liban tombe dans le chaos parce
que ça aurait un impact très néfaste sur
eux et donc la seule solution pour eux
et l'établissement d'un état
il ne s'agit pas d'appeler à une
intervention étrangère mais de déclarer
très clairement qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce
dont le pays a besoin et de commencer
éventuellement à le déclarer à le
déclarer très clairement de façon
maintenant vous coupez mais vous dites
voilà votre parti souhaite à un état
laïc
aujourd'hui clairement est ce que les
conditions sont réunies pour la création
de cet état laïc ça semble si compliqué
écoutez le pô le problème c'est que
c'est le seul régime qui une légitimité
capable de gérer la crise ce n'est pas
parce que nous parce que la situation
s'y prête ou pas ou parce que certains
ont envie ou pas malheureusement le
régime actuel je pense que c'est devenu
clair votre reportage a été très clair à
ce niveau là est incapable de gérer la
crise il
c'est une crise de régime ce n'est pas
une crise économique ce n'est même pas
une crise qui est simplement politique
d'accord c'est une crise
fondamentalement de régime est donc le
seul régime qui soit capable de gérer la
crise soit enfin la seule la seule
entité institutionnels qui sont capables
de gérer une crise pareille est un état
et dans l'état des choses au liban cet
état ne peut avoir qu'une légitimité
naik s'il veut avoir la chance de se
maintenir et de véritablement death
tribus et les pertes de façon équitable
et avec un objectif parce que
aujourd'hui c'est ce que les libanais à
temps merci m mounir douma ni un membre
du parti libanais citoyens et citoyennes
dans un état d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
au brésil à présent l'étau se resserre
sur le président brésilien vale sonar ou
la commission sénatoriale qui enquête
depuis deux mois sur les défaillances de
la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement brésilien poursuit ses
auditions
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite à augusta lunar vie journaliste
indépendante en direct de sao paulo
bonsoir de sa la commission sénatoriale
qui a donc pris connaissance de
nouvelles révélations qui met à mal le
camp bolton à rouen oui bonsoir
exactement cette commission sénatoriale
a pris connaissance d'un scandale
financier qui vient entacher le mandat
de gerbe le sonar ou trois sénateurs
brésiliens ont demandé lundi dernier à
la cour suprême l'ouverture d'une
enquête contre le chef d'état accusé
d'avoir fermé les yeux sur des soupçons
d'irrégularités dans l'achat des deux
vaccins un couvent active du laboratoire
indien barak
pardon baratte bio tels selon la presse
brésilienne de barack biotech avait
initialement proposé le vaccin à 1 $ 34
par dose alors que les vaccins que le
vaccin n'avait pas encore reçu
l'homologation des autorités sanitaires
brésiliennes mais le gouvernement vole
sonar ou a finalement accepté de payer à
la place 15 dollar par dose soit plus
que pour tout autre vaccin qui n'est
jamais acheter donc hier soir un nouveau
scandale concernant l'achat des vaccins
anti corrida eu lieu le quotidien folha
de sao paulo a révélé que dans le cadre
des négociations pour l'achat des
vaccins
astrazeneca entre le ministère de la
santé brésilien et le groupe
pharmaceutique da vaty un pot de vin de
1 dollar par dose aurait été exigé par
la partie brésilienne en échange de la
signature du contrat dont selon le
journal le directeur de la logistique au
ministère de la santé est impliqué le
gouvernement brésilien a annoncé son
limogeage
hier soir et augusta les opposants du
gouvernement molson à rouyn qui organise
d'ailleurs en ce moment brasilia le
dépôt d'une super pétition demandant la
mise en accusation du président
brésilien
oui exactement vérité
plus les auditions de la commission
sénatoriale ce succès de plus les
accusations s'aggrave le gouvernement
vole sonar aux arrêts j'étais des offres
d'achat de plusieurs millions de doses
du vaccin father à plusieurs reprises le
ministère de la santé a tenté de
modifier la notice de la chloroquine ray
mais de scientifiquement prouvé
inefficace contre la copie de 19 entre
autres auraient irrégularités commises
par la gestion du président brésilien et
son gouvernement face à la crise
sanitaire face à la pente et les
réprésentants de 46 partis politiques
d'opposition sont en train de déposer en
ce moment au parlement à brasilia
super demande de destitution de bolt
zone euro qui en plus de vouloir
responsabiliser son gouvernement des
plus de 500 1 1000 décès liés à la cause
l'éditeur va également apporter les
accusations de corruption dans l'achat
de 25 go vaccine et astrazeneca
donc on vous avait dit un rassemblement
est en train d'avoir lieu en ce moment
devant le congrès national à brasilia la
capitale du pays et des nouvelles
manifestations sont prévues ce week end
comme d'ailleurs tous les derniers
week-ends depuis trois ou quatre
semaines
les manifestants se réunissent partout
dans le pays pour demander bien sûr plus
de 2 de vaccin car la vaccination au
brésil marche encore très très lentement
mais surtout la destitution du président
jaillir ball sonar est justement vos
leçons a row clairement contestée est ce
un risque pour son avenir politique
déjà est d'ailleurs en forte baisse ce
sont ces soupçons de corruption siebel
sonar en continu de protéger les
responsables il peut en effet en ruine
et son programme anti corruption s'était
à son bourreau un programme lors de son
élection en 2018 qui a d'ailleurs aidé à
l'aller lire mais si les abandonne ils
risquent de rompre son alliance avec les
députés et les sénateurs de centre c'est
un groupe hétérogène de parti
conservateur qui lui a notamment permis
d'empêcher la progression parlementaires
de plus de 120 pétition de destitution
contre lui mais une chose est claire la
popularité de bolton arrow est en baisse
est en chute depuis plusieurs mois
depuis plusieurs semaines aussi à cause
de la pandémie bien évidemment mais à
cause de l'augmentation du taux de
chômage de la pauvreté de la population
qui aussi à cause de la fin de l'aide
d'urgence versées aux brésiliens aux
tous premiers mois de la pandémie n'a
rien métier en depuis le début adieu
mamba de germolles sonar ou en 2019 plus
de 120 demande de destitution ont été
déposées mais la procédure ne peut pas
être ouverte que si le président de la
chambre basse décide de la soumettre au
vote et ce président étant donné qu'il
est un fort et allié de bolton arrow le
scénario est encore imprévisible il
faudra attendre encore quelques semaines
quelques quelques jours quelques
semaines peut-être avec beaucoup de
pression populaire le président de la
section pro bass voudra ouvrir cette
cette procédure de destitution de bol
sonar ou merci à costa vous n'aviez j'en
ai assez indépendante d'avoir été avec
nous en direct de sao paulo et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain point complet sur les
qualités à 22h avec emilie google
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20 heures
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues kb
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
feront normalement les cellules
sensibles à la lumière dans la rétine
pas ce qu'il va dire qu'il voit un peu
c'est il distingue la lumière il
distingue quoi exactement
alors le patient avec la pop 1 par
exemple de reconnaître les passages
protégés dans la rue de détecter des
objets différents objets de petite
taille de grande taille à plusieurs
niveaux central de les compter de les
attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui voyait
plus rien depuis une quinzaine d'années
c'est déjà une source d'espoir c'est
évidemment pas un point définitif du
parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous